bienvenidos al segundo vídeo de
problemas de aplicación
relacionados con edades aquí ya tenemos
un problema escrito veamos que lo que
nos está planteando salman o sea yo
tiene 108 años de edad y esto claramente
es en el futuro es ficción solo sucederá
si cuido mi salud así es que salman
tiene 108 años de edad y jonathan tiene
24 años de edad en cuántos años la edad
de salman será exactamente cuatro veces
la edad de jonathan calculemos esto
supongamos que la variable y usemos
ahora que en vez de x supongamos que ya
es años
hasta qué
sal abriremos salman con sal tenga
cuatro veces la edad de jonathan bien si
el día de hoy sal yo salman chispas
es difícil referirse uno mismo en
tercera persona pero si actualmente sal
tiene 108 años en años más sal va a
tener 108 más y esto va a ser la edad de
sal en y en
años dentro de 10 años sal va a tener
108 más años mientras que para jonathan
es fácil ver que va a tener 24
años el 24 más lleva a ser yo no voy a
poner ión por jonathan
y
años esa va a ser la edad de jonathan en
10 años 24 más que más nos dice el
problema nos preguntan en cuántos años
la edad de salman será exactamente vamos
a subrayar esto para enfatizarlo
exactamente cuatro veces la edad de
jonathan y eso exactamente es importante
pues actualmente la edad de salman es
más de cuatro veces la edad y jonathan y
lo que queremos calcular es cuando va a
ser exactamente cuatro veces la edad de
jonathan tenemos entonces que en diez
años la edad de sal va a ser
108-108 más y va a ser la edad de sal y
eso queremos que sea exactamente cuatro
veces cuatro por la edad de jonathan 24
más jeff y ahora simplemente resolvemos
la ecuación tenemos 108 más y es igual a
4 por 24 es 4 x 25 es 100 menos 4 96
+ 4 que despejamos y luego asalta
algunos pasos pues esto debe ser fácil
para ti
es igual a
13 es igual a 108 menos 96
esto nos da 3 igual a 108 menos 96 12
correcto si 3 es igual a 12 de donde ya
es igual a 4
así es que usando álgebra hemos obtenido
que en 4 años salman va a tener
exactamente cuatro veces la edad de
jonathan veamos se cumple en cuatro años
salman va a tener 112 años mientras que
jonathan va a tener 24 y 428 veamos
entonces 28 por 48 por 4 32 y 80 112 si
efectivamente nuestra respuesta es
correcta excelente hagamos otro nuevo
espero que no hayas oído eso es mi
estómago gruñendo trabajamos tan duro de
este lado que no me he dado siquiera
tiempo de ir a comer muy bien hagamos
otro problema pero ahora lo voy a
escribir
veamos
raúl
tiene
actualmente
cinco veces la edad de armando hace
85 años y este es realmente un intervalo
de tiempo muy largo hace 85 años raúl
tenía 10 veces la edad de armando
qué edad tiene armando
actualmente veamos cómo lo abordamos me
parece que es un problema muy
interesante déjame hacer los ajustes de
mi pluma
vamos a proceder como en el primer vídeo
hagamos para empezar una tabla veamos
entonces nos están pidiendo la edad de
armando actualmente así es que vamos a
poner aquí armando
al mando y actualmente también tenemos
cuál es el otro periodo de tiempo que se
está considerando hace 85 años hace 85
años una galaxia realmente lejana muy
bien los protagonistas son armando y
raúl
raúl lo que queremos encontrar es la
edad de hernando actualmente así es que
vamos a asignarle la variable x raúl
tiene actualmente cinco veces la edad de
armando vamos a subrayar esto
actualmente raúl tiene cinco veces la
edad el mando si la edad de armando es x
la edad de raúl es 5 por x 5 x hace 85
años si actualmente armando tiene x años
entonces hace 85 años armando tenía x
menos 85 mientras que raúl que
actualmente tiene 5x años hace 85 años
tenía 5x menos 85 simplemente ha restado
85 años de las edades actuales pues
vamos 85 años hacia el pasado y también
tenemos esta información que aún no
hemos utilizado nos dicen que hace 85
años raúl tenía 10 veces la edad de
armando así es que este número va a ser
10 veces este otro número eso es lo que
nos están dando con esta información
cinco años que es esta situación la edad
de raúl era diez veces la edad de
armando vamos a escribir eso
matemáticamente con una ecuación la edad
de raúl entonces era 5 x menos 85 lo
cual en ese momento era 10 veces la edad
de armando 10 que multiplica a x menos
85 y ahora simplemente resolvemos la
ecuación tenemos que 5x menos 85 es
igual a 10 x menos 850
despejamos x tenemos entonces voy a
saltarme algunos pasos para confundirte
5x es igual a buff creo que el que se
confundió fue otro la veamos 5x es igual
a 850 menos
85 y esto a cuánto es igual
850 menos 85 sería 35 menos de 800 35
menos de 800 es 5x es igual a 7
765 obtenemos que x es igual a 775 entre
5 hagamos la división 7 entre 5 es 11
por 55 restamos nos queda 2 bajamos el 6
26 entre 50 y 55 por 525 restamos 25 nos
queda 115 entre 5 es igual a 3x es igual
a 153 vaya que viven muchos años estos
tipos hemos obtenido que armando tiene
153 años de edad actualmente
veamos si esto es cierto si armando
tiene 153 entonces raúl espérame esto no
puede ser aquí hay un error casi se me
acabe el tiempo tengo que ver dónde está
el error a ver veamos si armando tiene
153 si armando es x raúl es 5 x eso hace
sentido ya ya vino esta mi error yo
pensaba que raúl era menor que armando y
no podía ser no no no raúl es mayor que
armando
tiene cinco veces la edad de armando que
es setecientos sesenta y cinco años vaya
vaya podría ser matusalén así es que
raúl tiene entonces setecientos sesenta
y cinco años y si nos remontamos a hace
85 años entonces raúl cuanto tenía raúl
tenía en ese entonces
haber para no hacernos bolas vamos a
escribir eso aquí entonces tenemos que
actualmente armando tiene
153 años y raúl hemos obtenido que raúl
tiene
765 que pasó hace 85 años armando tenía
153 menos 85 en cuanto es esos 150 menos
80 y 72 72 años mientras que raúl tenía
775 menos 85 espera esto no me está
checando donde me equivoqué y sólo me
quedan 10 segundos
no lo vas a tener que checar por tu
cuenta vamos a terminar aquí este vídeo